Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi and welcome back to the The
Ashton Podcast.
So today's episode is all about
cycling and it's something that
anybody knows.
Me, I'm passionate about.
I'm a keen cyclist.
I'm one of these people who
watches nearly all the races,
not just the Tour de France, but
the Classics, the other Grand
Tours and basically any cycling
race.
I'm I'm kind of obsessed with it
and that's partly because I just
enjoy cycling, but also because
I think there is a fantastic and
super interesting link to
aerodynamics.
Aerodynamics for cycling is one
of the key differentiators.
And actually to model the flow
over a bike is also extremely
challenging for methods such as
computational fluid dynamics,
modelling the movement of the
legs and the transition between
lamina and turbine flow.
And that's why the person that
I'm speaking into this episode,
Doctor Michael Hutchinson or
Doctor Hutch as some people know
him, is one of the foremost
experts on the practical
application of improving
aerodynamics or the aerodynamic
efficiency of a cyclist, whether
it's track cyclist or world tour
cyclist.
In this in this episode, we we
talk about so many different
things.
I think he is a really unique
character because he was a very
top level cyclist himself.
He holds numerous world records
in terms of time trials.
He did racing, he then moved on
and, and continues to do.
And I, I guess what a lot of
people know him as is as a
journalist writing for Cycling
Weekly.
He does some commentary on, on
Eurosport, he's written books,
he acts as a coach.
He was very involved with the
British Cycling in some of the
foremost years where that those
marginal gains and the real sort
of development of aerodynamics
came in.
And I think he is one of those
pioneers who, as we, you know,
discuss in the early days was
doing things in wind tunnels,
Even talks about having his own
wind tunnel in his lounge.
Really someone who wanted to
tinker and really understood the
importance of it, arguably well
before it's commonplace today.
One of the first people to have
power meters on his bike to sort
of try and figure out where the
game was coming from.
Just so many things that I found
fascinating and I also took the
opportunity to speak to him at
length about how things have
changed.
One of the common questions you
know you get is around why are
the cyclists today so much
faster than the ones before?
Is it to do with equipment?
Is it to do with training?
So we go through all those
discussions about how trainings
change nutrition, aerodynamics.
I like I said, I this was a
dream for me.
It was talking about stuff that
I found fascinating and hearing
from one of the from the experts
was was great.
So this is one definitely for
cycling fans, but hopefully also
for people just interested in
aerodynamics, cycling CFD and
just hearing from a fantastic
person about his his life story
in a way, even though, yeah,
he's nowhere near complete.
So yeah, sit back and enjoy this
episode with Doctor Hutch.
How did you get in to cycling?
What age were you, cyclist?
I was 22 or 23.
I'd been a rower, hadn't at all.
And I, I started, I rode for, I
rode for Cambridge Lightweights.
And then I stopped doing that
because I started doing a
doctorate and I just didn't have
the time to hang about the
boathouse while 8 undergraduates
got their lives together.
And I took up cycling as a kind
of, I kind of a means to not get
fat really.
I just was looking for a sport
that I could do.
And I tried running and I wasn't
amazing at running.
And my no partner's father was a
cyclist.
And he said, yeah, borrow a
bike, go for a ride, see how you
like it.
And I liked it.
And that's Scott, how I got it
was also I liked.
It was also immediately obvious
that I was good at it, you know,
So you can tell.
I just tell I got kind of 5
minutes into my first bike ride
and thought, actually, yeah, I
can kind of do this.
It just felt right.
So that's that, that's how I
came into it.
And that's why I ended up having
a slightly funny cycling career,
because I started 10 years too
late.
Yeah, so that's.
So that is quite late, isn't it?
I mean, you know, a lot of
people now are like 8 years old,
Yeah, on a bike or something.
But you have the card I mean. 13
or 13 or 14 or something. 13 or
14 or something.
It would be a good time to take
up cycling because you're kind
of you're old enough to plenty
of people take it up younger,
but if you took it up by 13 or
14, you wouldn't be losing out
very much.
If you take it up when you're in
in your 20s, you are you're
going to be running to catch up.
Some.
Some people do it.
Yeah, and how, how did you then?
What made you want to go?
I mean, there's a keen amateur
cyclist which you get, but but
you went further than that,
right?
So what were you always a
competitive?
Person.
To do that.
Yeah, well, it's, yes, it's
partly that.
It's also the kind of the
feeling you find something
you're good at.
How good can I be?
Because I was a reasonable
rower, but I was obviously not
rowing internationally.
I kind of university level
rowing was clearly my limo and I
found something I thought I
could probably be better at and
I could do it on my own.
So I wasn't dependent on anybody
else.
So I kind of just chased that
and got faster over two or three
seasons.
And then in 1999, which feels a
long time ago, I was second in
the national 10 mile
championships.
I won the season long circuit
series.
All of it was a little bit of a
surprise.
I'd, you know, I'd had a good
winter, I'd trained well and
suddenly that year I was I was
flying.
I was maybe my third season.
And yeah, I hadn't necessarily
been the plan.
I hadn't started out when I took
up cycling thinking I am going
to win this, this, this, this
and this.
I just sort of followed what I
thought would work.
I did actually.
I mean, I started being
interested in the aerodynamics
of it back right back then
because it seemed to me, well,
you kept reading that 80% of the
drag was, was, was from the from
his aerodynamics.
You think, well, why is everyone
else ignoring this?
Do we not believe this?
And I did, I did a four up race,
a university 4 up race with
amongst other people, an
engineer who sat down and did
some really basic modelling
with, I mean literally a piece
of a piece of paper and a
calculator and said, right, the
optimum way to ride this is for
Michael to sit on the front for
50 KS and we'll sit behind him
because he just, he just
modelled it backwards from the
differences between our, our,
our personal best times and we
all went well.
That doesn't make any sense.
And we went and did the race and
it was blindingly obvious
afterwards that he was
absolutely right.
The fastest way the four of us
would have got round the course
of the bit if I just sat in the
front of the three of them and
sat behind me because I was
quite a lot quicker than them.
And that just made me think, OK,
so if you look at the kind of
the physics of cycling that
people talk about, actually
this, this, you know, if you
follow that, you get some more.
So that's kind of, it's both how
I took up cycling and I mean,
almost immediately became a
little bit interested in this
side of things.
Then I finished my doctorate.
I was working in an academic job
that was a one year contract.
And that came to an end and I
started looking for a job for
the following year.
And at a roundabout that point
somebody rang me one day and
said would you like to come and
ride for my team?
We'll give you some, they'll
give you some bikes.
As if there was a few 1000 lbs
of money involved in it.
I mean, it was about the same
amount of money as that I've
been getting from the academic
contract.
So it wasn't nothing.
And I thought, yeah, let's go
and do that.
Let's take a year and see.
A part of it was honestly, I
just like the novelty of
becoming a, a middle-aged,
slightly overweight, middle-aged
professor of international law
and having undergraduates go,
hey, Professor Hutchinson, he
won a cycling chat.
And the other one's like, no,
no, he couldn't possibly.
I just kind of like, I like the
idea of this being a kind of
slightly funny piece of back
story that was kind of, it's not
a great reason to become a
professional cyclist, but it's
more or less where I came at it
from.
And So what team what?
Tell us more about what?
What was that?
What was that like?
I'm writing for a team that was
essentially I was a one man
team, but I had a team manager
who ran a specialist, a
specialist to the time trial
equipment shop on on.
Well, I could have said an
online shop.
I think at this point it was
probably literally a mail order
shop.
I think you phoned him and told
him what he wanted.
It was like the dark ages and he
he done a deal with Giant with
Giant because Giant at that
point were making it where they
were making the Mike Burrows
concept of the compact bike
where instead of having bespoke
frames, you had three basic
sizes, a whole pile of different
seat pins and stems.
And Mike Burrows idea was that
anyone could fit anyone from
sort of five foot nothing to six
foot five could fit on one of
these three basic sizes using
the right bets.
And Andy, who was running the
team looked at this and looked
looked at this concept and said,
well, that might be true and it
might not, but I'll tell you
what, any one of these things
can be turned into a time travel
bike because you can get, you
know, but suddenly all of the
lengths and heights were sort of
independent of each other.
So you weren't dealing with
having to build a special bike
that was a little bit shorter, a
little bit lower.
You could actually do the
specialist geometry by using all
the bits that might had had
designed to make it fit anyone.
And he went to giant with this
and they and they said, well, if
you're right, we're going to be
able to sell these in vast
quantities to time trialists.
And he said, well, let me, let
me go and recruit you a time
trialist.
You will prove this point.
And he recruited, he recruited
me and they said my job, you
know, my job was to get my
picture in the cycling press or
by whatever means necessary.
It was sort of proto proto
social media.
That was the almost the main
objective.
The easy way to do it was to win
a lot.
So that's how I did it.
OK, so this and things have
moved on.
I guess at that time that whole
aerodynamics, I mean compared to
now where, you know, it is a
massive differentiator.
Everybody, even an amateur
cyclist is a sort of aero, you
know, obsessed person.
I guess then it was very
different.
Was it almost the opposite when
people didn't believe in it and
you were a slight outlier on
that side?
Yeah, they believed and they
didn't.
Everyone kind of, it was
perfectly clear that Tri bars
were faster than not using Tri
bars because IQ Tri bars came in
in the late 90s.
So everyone which was sorry, the
late 80s.
So it was a long time before I
arrived.
But it'd been completely clear
from that that you went
significantly faster if you used
aero bars than if you just kind
of grip, grip the cow horns in
the old in the old style.
So it wouldn't be quite right to
say that people didn't believe
in it.
I think there was a scepticism
about the subtleties of it.
I think if you got on The Time
Machine now and went back and
said, well, the difference
between this pointy helmet and
this pointy helmet is 2 seconds
a mile, I think you'd have
encountered some skepticism
about that.
I think people would have gone
the best as to a pointy helmet.
Skin suit should have been the
other big one because, you know,
you made it out of like her, you
made it reasonably tight.
That's it.
A skin suit was a skin suit.
So people believe in
aerodynamics.
They just didn't believe in the
small differences, and I kind of
did because I couldn't see why.
If putting a pair of Tri bars on
your bike would be to make you
2, two minutes faster over 25
miles, surely there were other
things you could do that would
make you 30 seconds faster over
25 miles.
So yeah, I started an awful lot
of very misguided homebro error
research, but along the way I I
stumbled in, I stumbled into
something, and I can't emphasize
how much more that was luck in
the judgement.
But is this something, you know,
you're, you know, having done
things like the 12 hour record
100 miles, To me as a amateur
cyclist, this sounds just
horrendously painful.
Is there a do you enjoy putting
yourself through that sort?
Is there something about those
longer distance that appealed to
you?
No, not at that point.
I I hated 12 hours.
I did 12 hours because I was
under degree of sponsor pressure
to do them.
I might have done, I might have
done the first one anyway, out
of curiosity.
I wouldn't have done the second
or third that I did in that era.
But yeah, interesting about
something like a 12 hour is it's
a competition between your
aerodynamics and your digestion.
You you as a bike rider are, you
know, the actual you're if
you're aerobically good, you
yeah, you've got an advantage.
But the big challenge is
actually keeping itching and and
keeping Arrow.
And I did, I've done some 24
hour racing in the last couple
of seasons as a sort of a sort
of retirement project.
And it's again, it's the same
thing.
It's about it's about eating and
about aerodynamics.
And how?
So I would say I don't
particularly enjoy putting
myself through things.
It's it's I'm much rather right
A10 than a 12A10 mile time trial
than a 12 hour, believe me.
OK.
So it was more, I thought, do
you have some sort of, I don't
know, thing that makes you just
love the, the, the torch of
going through long distances?
No, no, not to me.
I, I would always, I kind of
liked the races less if the
distances went up.
I liked, I like the kind of the
short races better because I I
enjoyed the kind of focus of
that and the high powers and
this the kind of the speed and
how all of that balanced quite
critically.
I like that much better than the
the adventure of going off and
trying to do a 12 hour.
It's to be honest, 100 mile time
trial isn't very different from
from a 10 mile time trial
because particularly if you're
doing it in sort of three hours,
3 hours, 20 or something, it's
not particularly long ride
because you're going quite
quickly.
You cover a certain amount of
distance, but there's plenty of
people who go and ride for kind
of ride hard for kind of three,
3 1/2 hours.
That's it's not that it's not
that hard.
It's a little bit hard.
I.
Was going to say.
It's not kind of a long distance
torture.
I guess it's more the being in
the position that I well, I
guess it depends on your
flexibility, doesn't it?
And like how used to you are in
that position?
And how how you trained in the
position, because it's one of
the changes I made fairly early
on was thinking if if I if I
race in a time trial position,
why am I spending my winter
riding around in a road bike?
So I built the world's first
winter winter low pro, a low pro
with mud guards on up from about
probably 2000 and four, 2005
before I came up with that one.
But yeah, I had I had a mud
guard low pro for for winter
training.
And what did people think about
that?
If they saw you on the road, did
they take a double look?
I don't think anyone ever really
commented on.
I mean, I didn't take it on club
runs or anything, so I'm not
sure how many people really kind
of stopped and went hang on a
second.
Those things don't go together.
I did a race on it once because
my, my, my years, my bike for
that year is an early season
race and my year bike for that
year hadn't come through yet and
it was muddy and I thought, I've
stuffed what I'll risk.
I'll I'll do this race with mud
guards.
But that's.
Never actually put them in the
wind tunnel.
Maybe they're, you know, maybe
they're a fairing, I don't know.
This is what you're going to see
now in the next track, mud
guards.
So what, what was how did things
then progress from there?
So you you sort of gone out
doing the PhD gone into, I guess
that you said, why not?
Let's let's try and do something
exciting, maybe talk what what
was the life after that like?
Or how did things progress?
Well, the idea had been to do a
year, a couple of years and two
or three years in I was still
winning a lot and reckon I could
win a lot more.
So I plugged away at it.
I had quite a nice deal in terms
of royalties on bikes and things
like that.
So I was making a reasonable
amount of money and I thought,
well, oh, I could go back to
being a legal academic.
I think I'm happy here actually.
So I just, I kept kept going,
did things like the
commonwealth's managed not to
get selected for the world's
until I'd more or less retired.
But I just found I kept making
progress.
I kept finding new ways to go
faster.
I kept meeting new people who
could help me go faster.
I did the R record in 2003,
which I didn't.
I didn't break the world R
record, but I learnt a huge
amount about particularly
aerodynamics in the course of
doing that and aerodynamic
testing.
And I always felt that every
year I was working through, I
was getting a little bit better.
I was finding new ways to do
this.
I kept think kind of stones I
wanted to turn over to see what
would happen if, and somewhere
around about 2005 or 2006.
I just think actually probably a
little difficult to just walk
straight back into an academic
job now because they're going to
want to know where I've been for
the past seven years.
And I'm not sure telling them I
was doing the Commonwealth
Games.
It's really going to be a big
selling point if you kind of
arrive at the Cambridge
University law faculty looking
for employment.
So at that point I thought,
well, I might as well ride this
to the bottom.
So I kept, I kept going.
I wrote, I've already started
writing books and things like
that.
That sort of had to be in a
different direction because I I
sort of became a cycling media
guy.
I started writing magazine
columns and writing books and
things like that.
So that that was a change as
well.
I was.
Going to ask about that.
Was that something that you'd
always like doing?
Did you ever do stuff with
student newspapers or did you
ever have sort of journalism
media thing before?
No, not really.
I I did some sort of freelance
writing in the winters in the
early, early season in the kind
of 2000 and one 2002, mainly
because I get a long way from
cycling.
There was a friend of my
girlfriend's who was editing a
book or a travel guide to
Ireland and there was a section
of Belfast, which is my native
city.
And she said could you read
this?
Because some of this doesn't
feel quite right to me.
And I read it and said it's not
really right.
No, She said could you rewrite
it?
And I said yes.
So I wrote quite a lot of a
travel guide to Ireland and I
did quite a good job of that.
So I spent kind of a couple of
winters actually writing and
editing travel guides.
So I had a little bit of
experience of that world.
And then when I did the R record
somewhere a week or two after
that, I thought, you know,
that's, that's quite a good
story because there's, there's
my R record attempt, which was a
little bit chaotic.
In the end, it's like all these
things, you start off with the
best of intentions and it ends
up being, you know, slapstick
and there's a whole history of
the R record and there wasn't an
English language book about the
R record.
So I, I said, you know, I wrote
a proposal and sent as a few
literary agents.
It helps that my, my, my
girlfriend is a, a publisher.
So I sort of, I knew, I knew the
world of, of what you tried to
do.
And yes, somebody, somebody
bought that as a book.
So I then spent a year writing
my first book, which did
reasonably well.
And say that's, that took me.
No, but no, it wasn't.
And it certainly wasn't the case
that I kind of did the R record
so I could write a book, the R
record and one or two of the
reviews, I sort of said, oh,
there's this joker who's had to
go with the R record just so we
can write a book about it.
I'm not well, that's really how
it worked.
I'm not a terrible bike rider.
And then I did another couple of
books after that for magazines
and things.
And that was kind of the
direction I went in for maybe 3
or 4 years before starting to
kind of get a bit more
interested back into some of the
technical sides of cycling.
And, and I think actually, you
know, your columns bring this
sort of funny side.
I remember reading something
about like bike ownership
recently.
You know, so many of the things
relate, like cycling is one of
those it is very well known and
equally not.
You know, it's, it's sort of got
a weird relationship, isn't it?
And to some people it's, it's
like a really hot topic.
But it's not from what I
understand.
And I don't know.
But you know, in Belgium and in
Holland, it really is like a
national support where the UK,
it feels like it's like a
subculture almost.
You know, some of my friends
were on WhatsApp all the time
talking where other people have
no clue other than the Tour de
France.
It's yeah, everybody knows what
it is because more or less
everybody can ride a bike.
So there's a familiarity to it.
Everybody knows what it looks
like.
It's one of those sort of
slightly second tier as a sport.
It's one of those slightly
second tier sports like
Wimbledon, like like tennis,
which comes up every year.
When Wimbledon is on, everyone's
a tennis fan for two weeks.
There are a lot of people who,
when the Tour de France is on
become something of a cycling
fan.
More so maybe a decade ago.
It was, there was such a, a high
watermark after London 2012.
Then the, the Tour de France was
in Yorkshire, the Jared Italia
was in Ireland.
It really was massive at that
point.
Everyone was a cyclist.
And now we've got to the point
where most people can remember
that.
So actually they know what they
knew then.
They're still a little bit
interested and they kind of, but
they pick it up and set it down
a bit as a, that sort of as a,
as a sport, as a pastime, a
little bit the same probably.
I think we have people who took
up cycling through the, the 20
tens, 20, fourteens when it, it
seemed to be everywhere and a
lot of them are still there and
still around.
But it it, it hasn't become,
it's not like football or
there's probably only space in
any country for one or two
really sort of dominant sports
that everyone is interested in.
In Belgium, cycling is the
sport.
In the UK, it's, it's football
and it always has been.
So you're always kind of
scuffing around looking for
whatever else you can find.
Yeah.
Before maybe talking about some
of the other media things, I was
interested, you know, you said
you started to get more into the
technical side.
So after the hour record.
So how when did you start to or
could you describe the link then
because that was sort of a bit
earlier, but just as British
Cycling was, was really trying
to get into more the
aerodynamics and the marginal
gains.
How was your sort of
relationship and over that with
some of that timing?
Yeah, I mean, I like I say, I
kind of had some home real, real
home brew stuff.
I built a wind tunnel on my
sitting room, which didn't
really work.
I said.
I was trying to say I built a
wind tunnel in my sitting room
and then I had it didn't really
work because if anybody thinks
it might have done, but I mean,
it produced results that made
sense.
But you know, it was basically
making little models of myself
and I'd kind of created a
balance of that, but it didn't
make a lot of, but it was
interesting.
You could actually see that off
the kind of little poseable
model.
You could see actual repeatable
differences from quite small
changes.
So that was a little bit
interesting.
The the big thing that I really
started to do when I was getting
ready for the our record,
actually, I kind of think that
biggest there was the other
thing.
The other thing I used to do was
just your frontal area analysis.
My finest star there was
realizing that if you took a
photograph of yourself head on
and then took another photograph
of yourself head on in a
different position.
Printed both the photographs out
onto a nice heavy sheet of
photographic paper and got a
scalpel and cut away everything
that wasn't you or your bike and
just weighed the paper.
You actually had quite a wow.
I probably at that point you
could just about you could
probably just about have done it
in a in a photo processing
software with a pixel count.
He's maybe a got on the early
side for that.
If you knew what you were doing,
you could have done that.
I did it a really kind of
analogue way.
So there were things like that.
But the first real point that I
started getting actual proper
quantitative results was using a
set of power cranks in an era
when power meters were unusual.
Just going and doing track
testing with a set of power
cranks.
And you did. 12 or 16?
Lap run and you just looked at
speed against par.
And I'd got a really kind of
basic, really basic spreadsheet
model that would just correct
for, you know, correct power for
speed so that you could correct
everything to 50 kilometers an
hour and it would just give you
your power for 50 kilometers an
hour.
And it, it clearly it wasn't
dealing with any of the vertical
forces and there was a certain
amount of noise in the system
and you couldn't find your Watt
one at a time, but you could
certainly if there was a 10 or a
15 Watt difference between
things, you could, you could see
it and it was repeatable.
It was laborious and it wasn't
cheap.
But one of the pluses I had was
that at that point my sponsors
were paying for my track time.
So I could book the track in
Manchester and have it to myself
for three or four hours at a
time.
And I would go up and do 12 lap
run, 16 lap run, come back down,
download it, take, take a take
kind of a nice section in the
middle of it somewhere that was
just nice.
And even I very quickly learned
that if you were on a rising or
a falling power trend, you were
in all sorts of trouble because
that just because the your speed
lags behind your your power.
So if the power curve wasn't
flat, but you could almost
always kind of deal with it by
making sure the section you were
taking started and finished on
the same par like usually dealt
with it.
If you were getting faster the
whole way through the run, it
was junk.
But if you have someone on
trackside who's giving you kind
of your splits as you go after a
couple of laps, you settled in
it.
It took a bit of experience.
You certainly you couldn't have
done it as a consumer
experience.
You couldn't just have brought
on a stranger and said, yeah,
come and do this.
We'll we'll do your aerodynamic.
It it took a lot of skill and
practice to make it work, but
it, it produced good repeatable
results that that then could
have would validate in the real
world.
And it the, the other really
basic thing that was interesting
about that was if you did
something like 5 laps of the
track with your elbows in a
natural position and then you
tucked your elbows right in and
you watch the trackside coach a
lap after you started doing
that, they would have taken
several steps away from the
start finish line, which would
indicate that you had just
started going faster.
And it had an immediacy that you
wouldn't ever see in the real
world by doing that and looking
at a, a bike computer because
you were maybe only gaining .3
or .4 of a kilometer an hour.
But when you do it on a
controlled environment like a
track and you're getting that
kind of lap by lap feedback, you
can immediately see the
difference it's making.
So it, it kind of firstly had
the effect of really making me
realize how very small changes
could produce very significant
results and, you know, the
beginnings of actually trying to
quantify these things.
And it seems like that's
actually a good point about the
power meters.
So when you know, again, they're
so commonplace now, so in there,
when did you start seeing them
more commonly used then?
Would it be in the early 2000s?
Or so 2/2/2000 I was involved
with the GB squad in 2000 and I
used one on the track there.
And then 2001 I bought 1 because
I had a lottery grant and I rode
from the rode race from Northern
Ireland.
The lottery grant system there
was you they, they, you couldn't
have like a living grant.
They would just buy you
equipment.
And the thing I asked them to
buy me in 2001 was an SRM power
meter, which I think in 2001
cost something like 2 1/2
thousand pounds.
Yeah, I was.
It was an expensive, it was an
expensive thing and it didn't
work brilliantly.
I ended up with two of them
because essentially you needed
one to use and one on its way to
repair.
Repair or on its way back from
being repaired.
But it was it was it was such a
powerful tool.
And I was still riding, doing
stuff with British Cycling and
they were very keen that I have
because that even in 2000 that
everything they were doing had
started to hang off par as the,
you know, their core metric.
That was Simon Jones and that
era was the head track coach and
he was a very numbers and a very
numbers driven coach.
So, yeah, the 2000, but at that
point, people would come up to
you at a race and point at this
thing on your bike and say,
what's that?
And you'd say it's a party, Here
they go, what's one of those?
And you would explain the
concept.
And a lot of them, some, some
people went, oh, it's brilliant.
A lot of people just went but
but why don't you just see how
fast you go?
And you would try to explain why
this was a more useful number.
But yeah, and I would say that
was at least a decade before
they became really commonplace.
And they'd been, I mean, they'd
been kind of prototyped
something wrong for a few years
before that.
But that was, that was pretty
much the beginning.
I I think I was kind of in on
the ground floor on that one.
And did you, you know in terms
of your training, I guess before
you were training on feel or
heart rate, did you, did you
notice a performance difference?
Heart rate.
Transitioning to power meters as
well.
And to be honest, not a huge
difference.
It meant what you were doing is
much more controlled.
You've got kind of real
confidence in it.
It probably it isolated kind of
training zones a little bit
better.
And particularly for kind of
lower effort training zones, you
could judge those more
accurately because if you're
trying to get like a Zone 2 off
a heart rate monitor, heartbeat
monitors are, yeah, they'll tell
you how hard you're working, but
they'll also tell you how warm
you are, how dehydrated you are,
how stressed you are, what your
blood volume is.
They'll tell you all sorts of
other things that will come into
that.
And you know, if you use a power
meter now, you notice there's
quite a lot of heart rate drift
even across the length of a
session.
So it made that more accurate.
It I probably got a bit fat.
I probably did.
My performance improved around
that era because I probably up
to that point overtrained a bit
if you go back to the 1990s.
And that wasn't really what we
were coming out the far side of
that.
But the training volumes people
did was insane.
I was, I'm doing, I'm writing
another book at the minute,
which includes some training
stuff.
And one of the things I was
looking at was kind of like some
historical training things.
And I found a recommended,
recommended by a coach training
program for doing a 24 hour time
trial that suggested, assuming
it is assuming you had a full
time job, but it was suggesting
that you could fit in a couple
of hours before work and
probably another 3 or 4 after
work.
And you did that five days a
week.
So what's that adds up to five
hours, 15, that's 25 hours a
week.
Then it suggested some long
rides at the weekend instead of
saying you could do six hours on
Saturday and six hours on
Sunday.
So it's racking you up to kind
of 3839 hours a week.
I said you should start doing
that in October and do it till
the beginning of the season.
And, you know, I, I think this
is being presented as sort of a
serious training program for
someone who really wanted to go
places, but nobody in the world
does that anymore.
And you were probably doing it
harder than zone 2 as well
because you were probably just
going out to ride it kind of as
hard as you could.
So I in, I had a great season in
2000 and one 2000 and sorry,
2000 I had a great season. 2001
wasn't as good because I, I
thought, well, I'm good at this.
I'll train harder.
And I realized part way through
2001 that actually I was just
knackered the whole time.
It was, there's a guy like a man
called Pete Keen who was the
first performance director of
kind of the British Cycling
organization as you would now
recognize it.
And I met him for the first time
in in Manchester around about
that era.
And he said, you're the most
exhausted looking cyclist I've
ever seen.
You need to train less.
And he did that literally.
I met him in a corridor and he
stopped me and said you're
Michael Hutchinson, I know you.
You need to train less.
Wow.
And he seems to have been right.
So that was right.
It's confounding variable
because that's around about the
point where I got my first power
meter.
And of course, I trained
probably dropped my training
mileage and my training volume
by probably a third between 2001
and 2002.
So who's to say the power meter
helped do that because it gave
you the confidence you could
see, you could see that the
numbers were going in the right
direction.
You could quantify that and you
could you could see that on your
own all winter.
You, you because before that you
would train all winter and your
first race of the year would be
terrified because you just
wouldn't know.
So you turn up to some dumb race
in February and right till you
could taste blood in your mouth.
So just prove that you could
still do it.
As soon as you've got a power
meter on the bike, you get to
February and go.
Well, last February I won a race
on 430 watts.
This February I can clearly do
the same thing.
So unless everybody else in the
world has got 10% better, I'm
going to be just fine.
So it gave you that degree of
confidence to to to have faith
in the training you were doing.
So yeah, it it was quite
important from that point of
view.
The thing is, that's what
everyone does.
Now.
The idea of that being novel is
seems kind of absurd.
Well, that, that's kind of maybe
one of the central question to
look to dive a bit deeper with
you is why if you look at italic
pagatcha or these, you know, the
current leading top riders and
then you contrast it back into
the 90s or the early 2000s.
What is it that is making them
beat all the records and then
smash away with it?
Is it the bikes?
Is it the training?
Is it nutrition?
Like how have you, how do you
analyse the progression and the
influence of each of those
factors in how they're going so
much faster now?
I I think nutrition's a lot of
them.
If you go back even 10 years,
the sort of standard target was
70 or 80 grams of carbohydrate
an hour.
And if you, if you've got a six
hour, if you've got Milan
Saidorama, 6-7 hours, all of
Milan Saidorama really is in
that last hour.
So you've got to survive that
first five hours.
And you can kind of the more you
can eat, the more you've got
left at the end.
If you can eat 80 grams of
carbohydrate an hour, well,
that's OK.
If you could eat 100 grams of
carbohydrate an hour over five
hours, well, that's another 100
grams of carbohydrate.
That's, that's like another half
hours high level riding in terms
of energy that you've you've
stashed away.
And most of the, the decent,
most decent pros these days can
do 120 a 130, maybe 150 grams of
carbohydrate in an hour.
So they're getting on towards
doubling what we used to do.
And that that's made a huge
difference.
And that's largely based on
improved sports nutrition
technology because there are,
for example, there are there are
different, different sorts of
carbohydrate have different
transport across the gut
membrane.
So fructose goes a different way
to glucose.
So the first thing that somebody
realized was that if fructose
and glucose aren't absorbed the
same way, well, you can combine
them into one sports drink.
So suddenly, instead of 80 grams
of carbohydrate an hour, you can
do 100 just because you take
your standard 80 grams an hour,
you put 20 grams of fructose in
it, you give it a shake.
This is literally, we used to
buy fructose from the
supermarket, like from the jam
making department put it in.
I mean, it was the sweetest
thing known to man and it was
probably been quite hard to
sustain for a very long time.
But suddenly you could do
another 20 grams of carb, you
could do another 20 grams of
carbide.
And it's we've moved that on
again into kind of different
delivery systems.
So that makes a difference.
That also helps with your
training, that helps in racing,
but it supports better training
and that that helps that.
I think training has got more
specific because we can measure
it better.
You can, you know, it's much
more straightforward to go to a
lab and get good results and
then go and do kind of lab type
testing in the field so that
that that Physiology to work
with teams can actually monitor
what's going on and what
progress they're making without
having really to go to a
laboratory anymore.
So to that extent, training has
improved like a lot of things, a
lot.
Sometimes people say, what do I
think's made the biggest
difference of cycling in the
last 20 years?
And I say the ability to measure
stuff because it's so much
there's so much less guesswork
involved.
And a lot of the time it's not
something that a physiologist or
an arid analysis from the year
from 1999 wouldn't have
understood.
It's just that a, a physiologist
or a nutritionist or a, or an
arid analysis from 25 years ago
wouldn't have been able to
measure except under very
specific lab conditions.
All of the, all of these things
make, make make a difference.
And there's, there is also,
there's a psychological aspect
in that the expectations people
have of themselves feed into
the, the relationship between
psychology and Physiology is not
one or two separate things.
There's an extent to which the,
you know, there's a central
nervous system input to your
physical capacity.
So that now that's an area that
there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on now that I must
admit I don't absolutely
understand, but so there's some
very good work in that.
So the reason they're going,
there are a lot of reasons
they're going faster.
The first one I would point out
would be nutrition.
And do you think so if if you
say nutrition and I'd agree with
you and that's sort of
interesting link to what you
were saying before is like, can
you stomach it?
You know, if you're doing like a
7 hour or I guess a Grand Tour
every day?
Have you got bowel issues?
Are you able to sort of
continually do it?
I guess you have to be
physiologically not have issues
with digestion or, you know,
irritable bowel syndrome or
something that just rules you
out from from that.
But what about the training?
Do you think that maybe it's
more as A and non professional?
I sometimes almost get a bit
confused by the different
advice, you know, that you see
on various websites or you know
YouTube channels.
Do you think the teams and the
riders all pretty much train the
same and they know?
Or do you think there is still a
lot of variation and uncertainty
on the balance of zone 2, zone
4, zone 5?
I, I think, I think you can get
where you're going a lot of
different ways in training.
I don't think there's a single
right way to train.
I think you could train the same
athlete two different ways and
get the same result.
The things you do certainly do
need to be aware of our overall
load because overtraining's a,
a, a proper problem.
Again, it's easier to measure
now.
It's, it's hopefully easier to
avoid those problems.
I mean, I kind of.
I interviewed within the space
of two weeks a few years ago.
I interviewed two different
coaches from the same elite
team, and one of them said it's
just about load.
Just, you know, you give the
rider the load they need.
It doesn't matter if it's zone
2, zone 3, zone 4, sprints,
whatever.
Give them the load they need,
adapt it by what they like and
what they'll do and what they're
good at, and you're fine.
And a week later I interviewed
another coach, slightly more
senior coach, but from the same
team.
And I did the thing that you do
when you want to look like an
expert, which is you quote what
the last expert you talked to
said to you, and you quote that
as an expert.
And I sat back expertly in my
chair and said, well, of course
it's all about load.
Yeah.
And he could.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's really specific.
You have to you.
And he he started into
explaining to me how you have to
find the right gradient of Rd.
at the right altitude to
simulate the exact effort for so
you work out where the attack on
up do is going to be and you
find a road that's that gradient
at the right altitude.
And you rehearse that.
It was completely different, I
think.
But, but, but you guys are
literally training the same bike
riders.
And that, that really interested
me.
I think specificity helps.
I think it also helps with, with
with motivation and it helps
give athletes a lot of
confidence.
And this is where it's athletes
are very complicated things and
and training an athlete is
thereby is a complicated thing.
I mean, athletes that I've
coached, I tend to work
backwards from the demands of
the event.
With World Tour riders, it gets
a little bit more complicated
and you maybe are in the
position where they've got a
target event, but they're
actually going to spend a lot of
their time doing something else
that they need to do to keep
their place in the team, to keep
actually being that World Tour
bike rider and living in that
environment.
So you do often at that level,
you have a lot of compromises,
but it still does basically
revolve around the specificity
of of the event.
And as I say, the fact that you
can measure people's progress
better, but I don't feel like
training has changed a huge
amount in the last 10 or 15
years.
People talk about, oh, we're in
modern training and I think
coaching has got better.
Athletes have got better at
providing feedback, We've got
better at measuring it, but
it's, it's been a fairly
marginal gain.
It, it hasn't been the same
scale as some of the aerodynamic
gain, some of the nutritional
gains.
I think, you know, you probably
publish this podcast and I get
furious emails from coaching
friends of mine saying, no,
we've changed this, we've
changed that.
But in the end of the day, it's,
it's not like, you know,
obviously there's a doping issue
in the past and cycling a little
bit of the current probably.
But that's another topic which
makes it quite hard to look over
time at things like records,
power to wet performances and so
on.
Because you go back to a point
where those rescued by doping.
But it's not as if in the last
10 years, amateur athletes with
decent coaching have started
doing 6 watts per kilo when they
were doing 5.
You know, maybe athletes who
were doing 5.5 point, 5 watts
per kilo, better coaching,
slightly more refined approach
to it, they get into 55.2 watts
per kilo.
It, it, it's not night and day,
it's an improvement.
And if you're at a race, well,
yeah, it's it's going to be a
decisive difference.
But it's not as if people are
suddenly finding 75 watts where
their dad couldn't have found
them before.
Yeah.
And I kind of wonder as well of
the salary side of things, the
professionalism that, you know,
if you're being paid millions
now compared to I guess what was
10s or hundreds of thousands,
whether the, the
professionalism, you know, you
see that in other like football
where they'd say, oh, we'd go
for a drink, you know, after the
game or something.
And now you would never do that,
you know, Did did you see that
as well, that the level of
professionalism has just the the
other stuff outside of cycling
almost?
Maybe, maybe I, my feeling is
that most of the riders I've
known or worked with have been,
they've been pretty
professional.
I think probably more
professional than a lot of other
sports.
The ones who've been good at it
and done well.
I've certainly, I've been very
in my kind of capacity in my
later years as a career.
My, my later part of my career.
I would go to kind of
international events as sort of
someone who was kind of
approaching 40 and you know,
riding in a team with, with
riders who were 2122, maybe even
a little younger than that.
And I was always really
impressed by, you know, they did
their strength and conditioning,
they did their stretches, they
went to bed early.
They took nutrition seriously.
You know, I think things, things
like that.
I've I've often been impressed
with riders who've done well
team to pick that stuff up quite
early on.
And I'm not sure that it's got
vastly more professional and I
don't think the attitudes share
among the top riders.
I think they always rode like
that.
I, I, I suppose it's possible
that if you come down a bit
further to a kind of a slightly
more mediocre level, there's a
higher degree of professionalism
because people it's, it's that
much more straightforward things
like social media.
It's that much more
straightforward to see how
people, how the good riders
live, how they do it.
You can kind of, you can go, you
can follow, you can follow sort
of top world tour pro and
Strava.
And so to see that, yeah, in the
offseason, yeah, they're reckon
they're not really riding their
bike, but you know what, they're
still getting out.
They're doing some nice easy
rides.
They don't take that long off.
They ease themselves back into
it because there's all these
things that you kind of know
you're supposed to do.
But it's very educational to see
someone who's really good
actually going out and and doing
them.
It's why in a team like the, the
British track team, there are
always, at any point where I was
involved in it, there were
always one or two kind of
tentpole athletes who the other
athletes looked up to.
Chris Hoy, probably the the
clear, probably the clearest
example of that, because he took
it seriously.
He approached it like a like a,
like a job.
He did the things the strength
and conditioning coaches wanted
him to do.
And people would look at that
and go, OK, well, that's this,
you know, that's how Chris does
it.
And Chris has I don't know how
many Olympic gold medals.
Well, you know, that's, that's
how I'll do it.
There is a there is a leading by
example.
If if you can see it, it's much
easier to to follow up.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
Then maybe I should say the
professionalism of the top
riders maybe hasn't changed, but
it's maybe the more of the, the
everybody is being more
professional.
So it's sort of like the
domestics maybe are sort of
rising up because everybody's
more, but so training how large
they sort of stayed there is
improvements, but you're saying
it's not a massive a nutrition.
For sure.
I think, I think what we have
with training is, I think what
we have with training is a
better version of fundamentally
the same thing.
I don't think anything enormous
has changed.
And I think, you know, we're,
we're better at suiting the
athlete to the, to the, the
training to the athlete and
getting the athlete to do the
right training.
But fundamentally, yeah, yeah.
And, and I guess the, as you
said, the, the data-driven
decisions, the fact that trading
peaks and all this sort of stuff
is you can see stuff where I
guess before maybe as you say,
they, they knew what they needed
to do, but they didn't have the
ability to track it or analyse
it to to the same extent.
And maybe I should count about
some of this that mainly have
been talking about men's
cycling, but there's been a huge
transformation also women's
cycling.
Did you see, how have you seen
that change?
Is it, is it similar to the men
in terms of just nutrition
training?
Or do you think there's bigger
differences on the the women's
side than the the men's side?
I, I think, I think that the,
the increasing opportunities
for, for, for, for women in Pro
Cycling means that there's an
opportunity to get it right.
I think they all, I think the
women's peloton have always
known how to do it, but very
often, even at relatively high
levels, you've got athletes who
are also working as coaches or
having to kind of balance
things.
And I think that's been that's
been the big change is actually,
you know, we're we're getting on
towards proper sized contracts
for a lot of the women's
peloton.
And if you went back 10 or 12
years, the top riders were, you
know, they weren't getting the
same contracts as the guys, but
they were at least able to ride
As for the proper full time
pros.
But that's been extended further
down the peloton.
So I wouldn't say they're more
professional in the sense that
there's been an improvement in,
you know, compliance to to
training programs and so on.
I think there's been an
improvement in people's ability
to actually take on, you know,
the kind of training program
that that helps them get to
their, it helps them get to
their, to their, to their best.
I think that's been a change,
yes.
I don't think it's been a change
of attitude.
It's literally been a change of
the business model.
Yeah, I I guess you're right.
As soon as people can have a
full time job, I guess you can
do more training.
You don't have to skip.
The, it's, it's, it's a version
of, you know, if you go back to
what happened in cycling, in
track cycling in the UK in the,
in the very early part of the
21st century, the biggest change
there was money that allowed
riders of both genders, of
mainly men in that era, but
allowed riders of both genders
to be full time to take it
seriously, to, to, to approach
cycling the way they knew would
work.
And it's just giving people that
opportunity.
It's it's, it's just money.
And that's the balance.
Isn't that here, some people in
some ways don't like the way
that cycling is becoming more
commercial and more things, but
equally that's bringing more
money into the sport and I guess
encouraging particularly on the
women's side, allowing sort of
more progression.
So I guess it's always a balance
of the of the two sides, but let
maybe shifting to the
aerodynamic side.
So obviously that has been a
made change, but in what sense?
So would you out of let's say
the bike, the skinsuit, the
helmet, if, if you were to take
the width is the one thing that
you think has been the most
dominant and and how would you
say that's progressed?
Of of the components, I think
all the things, it depends where
you start.
It's the same as I run wind
tunnel sessions and somebody
comes and says, oh, you know
what, what's the most important
thing going to be?
And I say what?
It depends how you're, it
depends how you arrive.
So there is that.
It depends if your baseline bike
is from 2010 or from 2000
because they were very
different.
In the time I've been involved
in it.
The biggest change I think has
been just looking at equipment
issues.
I think the biggest change has
probably been skin suits because
in the period of time I've been
looking at this property, the
bikes the bikes were were
decent.
We've had very few really bad
bikes in the last 15 years.
There've been a few, but most
decent manufacturers produce
decent bikes.
The wheels have been pretty
decent, but the skin suits have
have really moved on because if
even sort of up to I mean the,
the, the real watershed for that
was probably 2008, which was
the, the, the GB plastic skin
suits which were non air
permeable and tripped had like
tripped seams on them.
And all the riders had lessons
on how to put them on so that
the trips were in the right
place.
And you would talk to riders in
the track squad said we had a,
had a session a few, a couple of
weeks before the Olympics where
we all got our Olympic suits and
we were allowed to wear them.
And we all went onto the track
to do kind of training efforts.
And suddenly we were setting PBS
left, right and centre.
And we, we just, we just
couldn't believe it because they
told us about these amazing
suits.
And we thought, well, skin
suit's a skin suit, you make it
tight, it doesn't flap, doesn't
have any wrinkles there we are
job done.
And we put these things on and
suddenly people were riding, you
know, 2 seconds a kilometre
faster.
And that that was a real wake
up.
Those suits immediately got
banned.
But at that point, everybody
suddenly was saying, OK, so this
is this is not as simple as we
thought.
And the first skin suit projects
I was involved with were already
happening by the end of 2008.
And this was the lead up to the
London Olympics, I guess, where
the the real sort of moment
happened.
Yeah, yeah, they, I mean the UCI
changed the regulations so that
all the skin suits had to be a
tech had to be a textile suit
basically the rule which you had
to be able to blow through it.
So it had to be a nested fabric
essentially.
And I think the assumption was
that that was going to be the
end to this kind of plastic skin
suit, the larky.
But you had a very rapidly
discovered that what you do with
textures and trips it it all
still works on a on a textile
suit.
And actually, a textile suit is
much better because you couldn't
wear one of the plastic suits
for a 40K time child, because
you'd be like a boil in the bag
checking every, you know, you,
if you wrote, if you wore one of
those suits, you couldn't you,
you couldn't feel the air
hitting you apart from your
knees and your face.
It was, I mean, I never wore
one, but everyone I know who did
said it was a very old sensation
because you did big tall over
shoes that came to just below
your knees and your shorts that
came all of us.
So they said the only place you,
your kneecaps would feel cold
and everything else would be
cooking.
And as soon as you transfer all
of that know how to making a
textile so you can write, you
can wear it for a 40K time
trial.
And suddenly it, it, it's of
interest to world tour teams
because world tour teams aren't
interested in riding 16 laps of
a track.
World tour teams are interested
in riding 40 kilometers.
So suddenly there's a lot of
interest.
There's a bit more funding and
the differences you were seeing
in terms of total global drag on
on a bike rider, you're seeing
differences of four or 5%
between old skin suits and you
know, the good well fitted
modern, you know, current suits,
which is it's just huge.
It's, it's more than you're
going to get from a bike and
unless you're moving from like a
real old steel bike with exposed
cables and round forks and all
the rest of it.
But it's, it's that kind of
it's, it's covering, you know,
maybe two or three generations
of bike development.
So I suppose covering a couple
of generations of suit
development, but you know.
So is that maybe translating it
to the to the world tour teams,
the people that maybe we see on
TV?
So they're all wearing, from
what I understand, sort of skin
suit or or or partial skin suits
almost all the time.
Yeah, not a lot of jerseys
around anymore.
So the difference, I mean that.
So therefore that must explain
some of the difference in the
speed from like the 1990s.
So four 5% and they're going
faster.
So I guess the influence of the
skin suit is also therefore
bigger.
Would you say that is a a sort
of one of the key elements that
is making them if you put a skin
suit on one of the 1990s riders,
they would probably also go 4%
faster or?
Something on a on a, on a time
trial yeah, it's fairly simple.
It translates across it's more
complicated on a road stage
because there were a a big a big
grant or a road stage for AGC
rider is almost certainly
getting decided uphill where
aerodynamics counts for a little
bit less.
You then need to factor in how
much energy have they saved by
being more aerodynamic for the
excuse me, how much, how much
would they say about being more
aerodynamic for the sections of
the race where they're sitting
in the wheels?
What influence is the
aerodynamics having on their
their domestics or maybe trying
to control the race because
they're not controlling it at a
slightly higher speed.
So is everybody riding at the
same intensity but going because
if you're riding at the same
intensity but just going faster
on the flat, it's not going to
do you much good.
When you get to uphill, it's
because you'll have put in the
same amount of effort and
suddenly you're riding up hills
of aerodynamics matters less.
And actually it's kind of a
wash.
If you're at a time trial,
clearly it matters if you are,
you know, if you've got better
technology than than than
another team and you can launch
a one or two of your riders off
up the road in a brick, well
then you can make the other team
work that much harder because
your aerodynamics is better on
a, on a road stage.
It's quite complicated because
you know, it's all you've
achieved is everybody's going
faster or have you managed to
find some way to make your
aerodynamic advantage count?
So it, it, it plays into the
tactics and it's not, it's not
always straightforward.
Most of the time when we're
looking at speed records in in
World Tour cycling, in Grand
Tours, we're we're just looking
at climbing where the influence
is a little bit smaller in terms
of aerodynamics in that moment.
But if the aerodynamics have
saved you some energy getting to
the climb.
So it kind of depends how that
balances out.
Yeah.
And that was a really rubbish
answer.
I'm sorry.
I didn't really, I didn't really
give you anything you could work
with there at all.
I said it's complicated.
I should have said that and shut
up, no?
No, no.
The reason I say is I'm always
wondering if when you watch and,
and obviously we can get into
this, you know, when, if you
watch the commentary on TV or
the analysis afterwards.
If you take Formula One, it is
very well established that the
car plays a huge part to the
point that it even outweighs the
driver and that there's no way
that someone with a lesser car
is going to, you know, go as
well.
But with cycling, unless I'm
mistaken, it's not often as much
discussed that the the bike
they're using or their skin suit
I think could actually be making
a difference.
If it's only 30 seconds, they
win.
But do do, do you see that or do
you think the difference between
the teams is not as big or or do
you think that is actually one
of the reasons why one team
could be sort of doing better?
Yeah.
I mean, I think it can.
I think that can happen
certainly on the track you see
some very tight margins in, in
things like pursuits and kilos
and the timed events.
And quite certainly, yeah, at
that point the technology can
make a difference.
It also depends a little bit
what you define as the
technology.
If you take AI mean I've taken
bunch race track riders to the
wind tunnel to work on their
position on the bunch bike on
like a, a drop handlebar upright
bike.
And then you see one of them
clipping off the front in a
scratch race four or five laps
before the end.
There's a question of how, how
are they going to stay away from
the bunch?
So if you can pick them up,
let's call it a quarter of a
second a lap and they've got 16
laps to stay away.
Well, then that's that's 4
seconds.
And you haven't gained that
through hardware or skin suits.
You've just gained that through
education, but you can get, I
think you get the same thing.
I've certainly seen kind of
elite level world championship
time trials that are being won
by someone who, had they been
riding the equipment of the guy
who came second, well, yeah,
they'd have been second.
A lot of the time the margins
are big enough that it doesn't
make any difference.
But as soon as you're down
around, if you're into anything
much under a second a kilometre,
there's the potential for a
good.
I think the best world tour type
set up to get that kind of
margin over an average to per
world tour type set up.
So as soon as you're into that
bracket, you have to accept the
possibility that maybe the guy
that won it won it because of,
of, of the kit he was using.
But it's, you know, he's also to
some extent he or she's also
responsible to some extent for
that kit.
There are choices that get made.
The team decides where it's
spending money, It decides what
bike sponsor it's going with.
There's a tendency to regard
that as kind of an act of God.
And it's a series of decisions
that a team and a writer have
made.
And you know, if you go to
Formula One, I read an article a
couple of days ago that was
speculating on why Mercedes last
season wasn't Mercedes F1
produced a terrible car that
bounced up and down.
And there was, I read an article
that was speculating why that
was and it was talking about
kind of they reckon the wind
tunnel team had got it wrong.
And then regarding the wind
tunnel team, that's, you know,
it's, it's not as if the wind
tunnel team are a different
thing from the drivers of the
team at the race.
It's, it's all one organization.
It's, it's the same in cycling.
People are, you know, making
these decisions and and doing
the research.
That's, that's kind of what I'm
wondering if the next few years
evolution or five years of Pro
Cycling is going to go more into
the equipment because they are
going faster.
And as soon as they see that
actually their setup can be
more, then it will only increase
the investment because they see
it as legitimate area to
advance.
And, and to sort of, as you
said, even just saving the
domestic, if they have to do 20
watts less, they're going to be
fresher.
They can, they can push more.
Whereas I liked having one of
your articles and I think we're
all, we've all felt that, that
how do you really know the
difference between 2 bikes?
You know, every advertisement
comes out that is 8 watts more
efficient or something.
And then you think, yeah, but
what rider was on that bike?
You know, what was the system
level drag?
And it all seems a bit hand
WAVY.
You know, it doesn't seem very
like scientific.
And, and, and if you go to I
read a white paper of a bike
that was saying it was, what was
it?
How come it was it 10 watts
faster than their leading
competitor, who they didn't
name.
And if you look at the white
paper, they were testing at 55
kilometres an hour and 30°
y'all, which is, yeah, that's a
blow you off your bike type
CrossFit.
At that point, you're not
worrying about how fast you're
going.
You're just trying to stay on
the road.
Yeah, it's, yeah, I, I, I, I
think, I think you're right.
I think that can be quite
difficult to keep track of.
I think the good teams are
already doing a lot of this
because they're well aware of,
you know what we've talked
about, which is, you know, if
you can save energy, if you can
make life easier for, for your
dumb mistakes.
Even if you're making if, if, if
you've got a team that's got AGC
rider and, and maybe a sprinter
in it and you are responsible
for controlling the race for
stage after stage after stage.
If you can do that for 20 watts
less cost day after day after
day for your whole team, after
three weeks, you've, you've
saved a lot of energy.
So I think the good teams are
already working with their,
their sponsor, we're working
with their equipment suppliers
to, to try to get these things
right.
And certainly if you, it's
interesting how much World Tour
riders know about everyone's
equipment because they all talk
to each other.
So you'll find them, you know,
one, the the entire bunch will
know whose helmet is the fastest
because they'll be told one of
the riders will have done the
testing for it in a wind tunnel.
And then there are the results.
And they'll say, yeah, we tested
our helmet, we tested yours, we
tested theirs.
We tested those guys.
Our helmet was 5 watts faster
than yours, 10 watts faster than
theirs.
They all, they all kind of know
that stuff.
And I think, yeah, a lot of the
the better funded teams can
afford to take, can afford to
take this seriously.
And there is a trickle down of
knowledge because you can get
quite a long way by just going.
And you know, if you go around
and ask asking writers in the
bunch what the best stuff is,
they know they'll tell you.
And that then gets fed back to
equipment manufacturers.
And there's a certain amount of
kind of cross, cross
pollination.
Let's be polite about it and not
call it theft.
If somebody comes up with a good
shape or a good idea or, or even
like a good tunnel protocol.
Sometimes your engineers talk to
each other and somebody finds
like a good way to test helmets
that is produces better results
in the real world.
You know, this, this stuff
isn't, kind of isn't sealed off
from each other.
So there is, there is kind of a,
a level of progress, but it's
very difficult for one team to
suddenly find 2 or 3% that that
nobody else is finding because
everyone's everyone's working at
it at the same time.
Yeah, and I guess the, but the
counter example, I guess to some
of the aero is some of the
sprinters like, you know, Milan,
who are these massive guy where
you think surely aerodynamically
they must be paying a massive
penalty and yet they're doing
like nearly 2000 watts or
something.
And you think, OK, well, I guess
if you're powerful enough,
aerodynamics doesn't really
matter.
But then you have these other
riders who are like in a tiny
little ball.
So I guess there's always a a
balance, isn't?
It I mean, you go, there have
been there biomechanical issues
just in terms of how how
particular riders get the par
right.
I mean, yeah, if you're
sprinting at 2000 watts, well,
aerodynamics counts for
something because you're you're
only trying to win by half a
wheel or less.
And you might only have
effectively a single.
If you couldn't.
I would think of it as kind of a
Sprint, a Rotary Sprint that's
happening over more or less a
single lap of the track.
But you can get in 1/4 of a
second at a lap in aerodynamics
if, if you've got to get good
versus bad, you're not kind of
really having to deal with the
the absolute outliers.
So, yeah, you can gain that, but
if you're doing it, you're
compromising what someone can do
in terms of their power.
You you have to balance those
things.
And for those guys, yeah, it
works out a bit differently.
I mean, I know one sprinter who
talked about one thing, longer
axles on his pedals because he
felt that gave him more leverage
as he throws the bike from side
to side.
He's got more width.
So I'm, I'm not completely
convinced about that, but it's
one of, you know, it's an
interesting example of the kind
of thing that actually, if you
were looking at the system
properly, that's one of the
things you would, you would have
to look at because it's not in
most cycling, most endurance
cycling is centrally governing
that.
It's got to do with the heart,
the lungs, the aerobic system.
Those kind of sprints aren't bio
mechanically, they're very
different and you could produce
a better, a better aerodynamic
solution, but you would be well
advised to do it in consultation
with with with the bio
mechanics.
Now one of the things that I
found interesting when I was
doing some stuff myself with BC
was the riders.
And I'm just wondering how you
have found this, which is I
observed quite a lot of like
superstition almost.
And you know, people felt like
this is better.
Do riders now more firmly trust
sort of aerodynamics advice and
positioning advice or how much
do you find?
There is still a gut feelings
and and and superstition.
I don't.
I don't know if you understand
what I'm getting at.
Yeah, I, I understand the
question.
I, I think there's been such a
history of the science being
right that most riders at the
very least acknowledge that they
ought to try things.
The, the, the GB sprinters were
the first guys who turned up
with 35 centimetre minimum width
bars.
And as I understand that a lot
of that had to do with Chris
Hoy, because all the most
sprinters in 2000 and seven,
2008, if you said, right, we
need you to race in 35
centimetre bars, they'd say, oh,
no, we won't have the, we won't
have the leverage, we won't have
the control.
We can't do that.
And, and Chris, I think said, I
tell you what, let's try it.
The only way we're going to find
out.
Let's let's go and do a Nation's
Cup or something and we'll do it
on the narrow bars and we'll see
how it works.
And, and it worked.
And it's one of the reasons you
need those riders in your team
is that you want somebody like
him to say, let's try it.
Jason Kenney was kind of the
same.
He would be a guy who would who
would say, OK, new bike, yeah,
let's try it.
And, and if he tried it and
liked it, a lot of the other
riders would go, well, if it's
good enough for Jason, it's good
enough for us.
But yeah, I think, I think bike
riders, if you test people at a
tunnel, it's surprising how
often they turn up and say, I do
this because of this.
There would have been a point.
There would have been a point
kind of before I was really at a
point where more I was in in the
tunnel as a subject than in the
tunnel as a technician.
But they're doing points where
people had turned up and said,
I, I want my, I want my elbow
shoulder width apart because
that's in front of my knees
because that's fastest because
that test.
And often they'd be talking back
to things like Chris Borbon did
his first tunnel sessions way
back in 1992 for the Barcelona
Olympics.
They said, OK, you need your
arms flat and you need them knee
width apart.
So it all lines up and fairly
basic testing also running at 0
yo because they're getting ready
for the track.
But 20 years later, you people
who would still be that because
that was a data point that
they'd had faith in for 20 years
something.
And they, they and there was a
logic to it and you'd sort of
say, well, we need, well, let's
change that.
And there be a bit of resistance
just because firstly, they
genuinely think it's fast.
And secondly, if they're wrong
and they've spent 20 years
getting this wrong.
So there's almost like a, some
cost policy to it as a
superstition isn't yeah, I know
what you mean by superstition.
It's not really what we're
dealing with, but it's, it's
just people who tested something
or have a friend who tested
something.
I think it's got lesser because
more people test individually
and accept that it's different
for different people.
I mean, I still occasionally you
read magazine features on what's
the fastest helmet.
You go, well, that's really an
answer to that question.
It's you can find the fastest
helmet on you for a particular
race if we're going to be picky.
But I think it's less of that
because I think there's much
more of an acceptance that it is
quite individual and you have to
find what works for you and what
works for you.
Even if you look at things like
the team pursuit squads now,
it's not at all unusual.
It's usually 4 riders wearing
four different helmets.
And it's not that long ago they
would always have worn matching
helmets because they're one,
because one of the riders who
would have done all the tunnel
testing so one of the riders
would have optimized their set
up.
And all the other riders who
wear what they wore because the
assumption was, well, this
helmet is fastest on Lucy, so
it's going to be fastest on the
other 3.
And you know, it's, it's not.
If you're going to get really
picky, you can start sort of
saying, well, which is the
fastest helmet on what rider in
what position in the string?
Because it doesn't depend on the
rider in front.
And you can disappear down, down
a rabbit hole plenty.
Plenty of engineers these days
don't because you can find you
can find very small margins of
these things.
And how much?
I mean, we spoke at the
beginning about track testing,
so you know, you have power
meters and obviously you have
the the real thing.
So I mean for certainly for
track testing.
But how much have you seen wind
tunnels change and evolve and
transform the sport?
Would you say that wind tunnels
have been one of the biggest
influence and the fact that you
can more readily go to them like
the Silverstone facilities?
It's it's it's made a yeah.
It's made a very big difference
because most of the serious
riders now will test
individually in a wind tunnel
and you don't have to go back
that far.
Before wind tunnel testing was
something really only done by a
handful of top end riders and
top end teams.
And even then they wouldn't test
all the riders they would do.
They had one or two riders who
would do all the testing.
Sometimes even riders who
weren't even competing anymore
would do all.
Jason Queley did a huge amount
of testing for Team GB after he
retired.
They did a lot of Skintoot
testing with Jason.
So yeah, it's the availability
of it has made a difference in
that firstly individuals go to a
wind tunnel, they find stuff out
and it's it's much faster than
track testing, It requires less
skill than track testing and you
can get a lot more data.
There is to me a little bit of a
debate in that you can produce
vast amounts of data from a wind
tunnel session, but how it
translates to the real world,
Sometimes it's very easy to
produce a riding position at a
wind tunnel that a that a rider
then will not do.
In reality.
If you test on the track, you're
testing in a slightly more
realistic environment.
Partly that's the skill of the
the wind tunnel arid analysis.
Partly it's properly briefing
the rider and partly it's the
rider understanding what they
need to do.
So you can get things badly
wrong in a wind tunnel, but you
can also in three hours in a
wind tunnel, you can belt
through maybe 25 or 26 different
setups.
And if you think about the sheer
physical nature of doing 25
setups 16 laps a time, so that's
25 times, that's 100 kilometers.
You know you're going to ride
100 kilometers in a day at race
pace, at that pursuit pace,
That's that's not going to
happen.
So that their wind tunnels have
made a very big difference.
And they have the actual, the
tunnels that we use have
improved in that they've become
much more focused on what we
need from them.
We started off using
aerodynamics tunnels and
motorsport tunnels, which are
fundamentally designed to do
something slightly different, so
that that's helped a lot.
The tunnels have got better.
One of the things that I've been
interested to know your thoughts
on this that I saw as a
challenge is sort of
repeatability because you've got
a human in a tunnel who you're
asking to be in a position and
then you're trying to test the
difference between two things
that may only have a very
marginal difference.
And I remember, you know,
various people have started to
explore, you know, mannequins
and then moving mannequins.
And I kind of wonder how that,
again, that's all my interest
between the F1 and the cycling.
I just kind of wonder where this
is going to, where this will go
to.
Are we going to have some, you
know, robotics moving around to
replicate?
Yeah.
How challenging is it to really
find the gain when there may be
a difference in the rider, the
way that they, you know, sit on
the bike?
It repeats, repeats, repeats.
You just do it again and again
and again.
If you've got the time, you just
do the repeats.
I mean, anything down below half
a percent starts to starts to be
in the noise for a normal rider
and a normal test.
And for most decent riders, you
know, if you're a decent male
world tour level rider, that's a
couple of watts.
If somebody says, oh, we did
such and such and we found a
Watt, I say, how many times did
you do it?
And if they say once, I say,
well, you don't really know.
In that case, maybe it's good,
maybe it's not.
Do it 3 or 4 times, get it 3 or
4 times, then yeah, it's
probably real.
And that as you, as you get to
finer and finer, let you know
finer trying to get finer and
finer resolution, you, you can
do more repeats.
Some riders are really good at
it.
I did a skin suit project using
a team rider who was phenomenal
in terms of her repeatability.
You would kind of do a test
you'd say, right, get off the
bike, walk around the tunnel for
two minutes, get back on the
bike.
Let's do that again.
Try to hit the same position and
she perfectly regularly would be
careful of doing 3 or 4 baseline
runs within .2% of each other,
which you'd nearly see that much
variation if you just did a bare
bike in the tunnel.
So if you find one of these
people, if you're developing a
skin suit or developing a helmet
or something, you find one of
these people, you hang on to
them.
It's no coincidence that she was
a scientist.
She, she's a doctoral and she's
got a, a science PhD, so she
understands what you're trying
to do and how important it is.
A lot of riders can do kind of,
yeah, under .5% levels of
repeatability.
And if you want to start looking
at things like wheels or tyre
interfaces and you want to do it
with a live rider on the bike,
either you, you, you preferably
you find someone who's good at
it and you, you do several
repeats.
And if you do that, you can get
to at a pretty granular level.
What of course you then struggle
to do is validate on the road
whether that's really worked
because it's now such a small
margin.
You're taking a lot of trust out
of the tunnel.
And you know, you get to a level
where I think we worry a lot
about the repeatability in the
tunnel and maybe not enough
about the validation back out
into the real world.
Because wind tunnels are quite
artificial environments.
The air in them is, it's been
through that lovely honeycomb.
So it's, it's all unturbulent
and flowing and lovely parallel
lines.
Go out into the real world, go
and ride a world tour time trial
where there's kind of there's a
motorbike up the road, There's
maybe a guard bike.
They've been, you know, you're
maybe if you catch another
rider, you're going to be in
the, in the wash of their team
car for maybe two or three
minutes.
And it's, I think one of the
things that we're going to see
in the next 10 years is better
examination of the real world
conditions because we've got
quite good at designing things
that work really well in wind
tunnels.
I'm not completely convinced
that all of that transfers into
into the real world.
Well, and that's.
Even at a really basic level,
you know the the go no.
No.
I'm going to see even at a
really basic level you're
dealing with a bike that's built
into the floor.
So the bike doesn't doesn't do
that.
So if you think a little bit
slight, how does that do to the
what does that do to the
effective Yaw angle?
Because almost nobody rides in a
ruler straight line.
So you know you're dealing And
then if you've got slightly
different Yaw angles or the Yaw
angle, the same for the front
wheel as it is for the rest of
the bike.
Yeah, and that's.
Probably in practice the
difference it makes is quite
small, but we're starting to
look for very small margins.
Now that's so interesting.
And I think to your point in F1,
from speaking to some colleagues
who still work in F1, I think
that is the growing challenge of
exactly that, of correlating.
You know, many, like you said,
the Mercedes issue, a lot of it
is because they develop in the
wind tunnel and then go to
track.
And when they test on the track,
they don't necessarily see and
they're like, how do I know?
And what's the difference
between the wind tunnel and the
track?
But they can't do track testing
to the same extent.
But that leads me to the other.
Now this is sort of my a lot of
my focus, but I'm interested.
What your opinion is this,
particularly as a someone who
does a lot of testing and
coaches and works with
companies, CFD computational
fluid dynamics is sort of build
and certainly if you look in the
automotive sector as part of the
solution because you can model
things and you're not confined
to the limitations of a wind
tunnel, but you have accuracy
issues.
How much have you seen that be
used in the development of
helmets and bikes more so than
just pretty pictures?
Or is is it still the case that
it's slightly not trusted and
people still really use the wind
tunnel as their, you know,
development tool?
Most most of what I've been
involved in has really just used
used the tunnel.
I've really only used CFD to
help visualize flow patterns to
think well, OK, that's
interesting.
There's a big low pressure area
there.
That might be an interesting
place to put a bottle fill in
that low pressure area, things
like that.
It's also fair to say that most
of what I've been involved in,
I've done more riders and skin
suits and things like that,
which is kind of bluff body
aerodynamics, which isn't really
CF DS absolutely strong suite.
It's getting better at it, but
if if you try to develop a skin
suit using CFD, you might get it
right, you might get it wrong.
To be honest.
It'll give you some things to
play with when you get to the
tunnel, but you could nearly
just as well have made a few
more prototype suits and and
done them in the tunnel Hardware
like bikes and helmets.
CFD is a much more powerful
tool.
I haven't done a lot of that.
Helmets I think is a a very a
very useful place for CFD.
Bikes are a great place for CFD,
not least because in suits and
and riding positions and so on,
you're working within some some
quite tight constraints.
The shapes and positions and
things you do with bikes,
despite the UCR rules, there's
quite a lot of space to play
with, like the the Hope Lotus
bike that, that, that, that Team
GB use.
That's not what the UCI expected
when they made the rules.
The UCI thought they'd come up
with a set of rules that produce
a normally shaped bike and
suddenly you arrive and go,
well, here's here, here's a
different thing.
And if you wanted to make a
series of randomly shaped bikes
and put them in a wind tunnel,
you'd have made a lot of
prototypes before you got to
that.
So it it particularly for
hardware, it can be a great way
of producing models to look at
and and paradigms to experiment
with because the the the danger
of any wind tunnel testing is
that you perfect the role model
by my favorite was the forks
that Team GB did for 2008, which
were very, very narrow and just
hugged just down the disk and
flared out to the hub.
And then 2012 they suddenly
produced a set of forks that
were the absolute opposite and
going in the direction of the
hope notice bike.
And it kind of turns out that it
doesn't matter what you do to
set a forks as long as you don't
do the standard straight leg
fork to the outside of the hub.
Wider is better and narrowers.
But obviously if you're doing
this in a wind tunnel, you say,
well, let's make a narrower
report.
You make one that's narrower,
it's better.
You go narrower again, we make
it narrower again, you go
brilliant, we've been done here.
And what you never tried doing
was making it wider.
You know, if you are one of the
things I would do in the tunnel,
if I'm working with a rider
who's got time and they've got
the budget to do it.
Let's say we go down 10 mil on
the, on the front end, very
simple and really simple
intervention.
Make the, the, the elbow pads 10
mil lower and that's better.
And we go down 20 mil and that's
better again.
And we go down 30 mil and that's
a little bit worse.
So you go great, 20 mil done,
job done.
If you've got the time, you
should go up as well because up
might be faster too.
It might just be that your rider
was in kind of a debts, but was
in kind of the bottom of AU
somewhere.
And, and, and you need to go in
both directions.
It's one of the problems is that
because you're a bit limited on
budget, you can end up taking
your best guess at what I ought
to work, finding it sort of
works and deciding that that
that's a triumph.
Job done, Let's go home.
When actually, you really ought
to look up a lot of other
options as well.
Yeah, I think that's when.
CFD can be good for that.
Exactly, that's why I think the
CFD does hold a lot of promise
and but at least from my
experience, the problem is
Formula One is really
complicated and so is cars.
But cycling is far more
complicated because you have
moving legs, which is incredibly
difficult to model in CFD.
You have transition effects by
design with skin suits, and
that's really difficult to
model.
And then you put them all
together and you have a problem
that's probably even harder than
modelling a car or or an
aircraft.
And you're probably doing it
with far less budget because
there's just less money in in
cycling than Formula One or or
cars.
So it feels to me there's so
much more that could be done.
You know, there's, there's more
Ave. like you said, most of the
time you come into a tunnel and
you test 5 things rather than
500 things because you just
can't manufacture 500 things.
But where maybe the question
then to you is more around where
should it go?
Because you could extrapolate
this and say, you know,
aerodynamics is going to do more
and more and more, but at what
point do you think there should
be the, where should the
regulations sit to avoid it
going too far?
Where do you think there's a
balance of the sport versus the,
the technology?
And is the balance correct now?
Question of philosophy, really.
What do you think the sport
ought to be exactly?
Do you?
Let's go, let's wind it all the
way back to the R The R record
attempt that I made was on, it
was called the Athletes R
Record.
So you had to do it.
The idea was you had to do it on
Eddie Merck's bike.
Basically you had to have a
round chewed bike, which the UCI
had kind of envisaged being made
of steel, but you could make it
or something else if you wanted
with a pair of old fashioned
drop handlebars.
And the idea this was going to
be completely standard.
First thing any of us did when
we got involved in this was
that, OK, what I make a really
long bike, what if make the bars
really narrow?
Let's get the spokes out of the
wheel.
You, you kind of and you ended
up bringing all the same
measuring and and testing to
bear on up that you would have
done to anything else.
You made less difference.
But because the margins were
small, you still have to do it
in F1 works on the basis they're
kind of going to restrict,
effectively restrict either
budget or in terms of either
cash budget or time budget.
And and they restrict the amount
of testing, which is a very
direct way of trying to level
the playing field in terms of
the budgets that people have to
have to play with.
I think it would be a difficult
job to create that effect by
changing the actual regulations
because the tighter you make the
regulations, you've got less
literal space for innovation in
terms of what shapes and things
you can make things.
But you're still going to find
the top teams looking for the
margins and measuring them.
So maybe, maybe you come up with
a really tight set of skin suit
regulations that make the
difference in the best skin suit
and the worst skin suit stops
being 3% and it starts being 1%.
You think you know, you, you,
you, you think Vismo Lisa Bike
are going to say, well, tell you
what, we, we won't bother
looking for that 1% anymore.
That 1% matters even more.
It matters just as much as it
did before, because everyone's
going to finish closer together,
but the winner is still going to
be the winner.
I so I, I think doing that with
regulations is really difficult.
And one of the, one of the
things the UCI have done that's
been a mistake in the past is
they've actually tried.
They haven't done it for a
while.
They've learned, I think they've
tried to reduce costs by
changing the regulations to make
things more restrictive.
And what you do every time you
do that is give a huge advantage
of the teams that have got the
budget, because every time you
change the regulations, you're
starting again from scratch.
So whoever's got the biggest
budget, you know, if the great
example of that is if they'd
left the plastic skin suit legal
after 2008, by 2012 everyone
would have had a plastic skin
suit and they would have been
quite close together.
They changed the regulations and
Team GB particularly went, hey,
that's great.
We know how to develop skin
suits and the know how from
developing the plastic skin
suits transfer straight across
to developing a textile skin
suit.
We're going to have an even
bigger advantage in London 2012.
And that's kind of that's an
example from kind of the last
from a decade ago.
But it it's, you will get that
if you keep changing the
regulations to try to keep costs
down, you're just giving an
advantage to the teams of the
budget.
You can now, you could now go
and win a World Tour time trial
on a 5 year old time trial
frame, which you could buy a
third or fourth hand, get
resprayed.
In terms of budget, you could do
that on the cheap.
It's not, not particularly the
issue because World Tour teams
are getting their bikes free
anyway.
But that kind of type forming
means that the, the, the, the
playing field has become a
little bit more level.
Because if you can get the
deltas between setups down from
5% to 2%, where you're much more
than the in the area of, of what
a rider can do now.
Because if you have a 5% delta
between a really good setup and
a really bad setup, but a rider
who's at the soggy end of that
is going around looking for 20
watts to catch the guy at the
front, If you can cut that down
to 2%, suddenly he needs 7 or 8
watts.
So, and in some ways, leaving
things as they are is is not the
worst approach.
Or you find a way of saying we
need to limit the amount of
research you can do that then
runs into problems because
Specialized say do a new time
trial bike and you say, oh,
well, yeah, but you're
developing that for a World Tour
team.
So you can only test that for so
many hours.
But they say, but we're selling
this, we're not testing it.
We're not testing it for, for,
for Quickstep.
We're testing it for all
mankind.
Anyone who wants to buy a bike,
you know that that that would
get quite difficult.
Yeah, it's and this is and
that's the same loophole in F1
that you know, where there was
like a certain team would, would
develop things through one of
their subsidiaries and then, you
know, transfer the technology
back.
And as you say, it's very hard
to to the loophole, but I, I
guess maybe you would agree that
it is still quite exciting times
for cycling in that there is a
lot more focus on it and there
is a focus on the technology.
And I actually think that's only
a, in a way of good thing.
Commercially it helps probably
more sponsors want to come in
because they see it as like an
exciting technology sport as
well as the human side.
And I guess my main question was
just to make sure it doesn't
create a too much of A like A2
tier system where it really is
because of.
The technology I think, I think,
I think it produces more issues
up to junior levels and things.
I think that is more of a
problem.
I, you know, I, I have the
National, the junior 10 mile
time trial a couple of years ago
was just down the road for me.
And I went, I went over,
actually I went over to report
on it because the magazine, I
write a column for it didn't
have a report for it.
So I said I'd go and do it,
which is kind of my job from
about 12 years ago.
But I went and did that.
And I was chatting to a friend
of mine who I used to race
against and whose son was now
racing.
And that didn't make me feel old
at all.
But he said, yeah, his, his, his
son's racing this year was going
to cost him was at £15,000 and
some of that things like
accommodation.
But he, he said that a certain
amount of it is wind tunnel time
now.
And this is kind of this, this,
this, this, this, this is a 17
year old rider who reckons to be
competitive, he needs, you know,
he needs good bike, he needs the
best skin suit, he needs the
tunnel time.
And The thing is, it's one of
the suggestions you find is, oh,
we should, we should make junior
riders ride certain, you know,
age of bike or they should have
to ride a road bike, I think.
But the problem is, it's, it's
not, it's not the equipment,
it's the tunnel time.
And that's always what you, what
you boil down to in any of this
is that because you're not
developing hardware, if you're
developing a car, it's a hard
object.
If you're developing and, and
you know, it's not like Mercedes
developed one car for one driver
and a different car for the
other driver, there'll be
clearly some mechanical set up
differences, but in terms of the
aerodynamics are the same.
Because like things so
individual, you need to test,
every rider needs to test
individually.
So it, it that, that produces a
significant skew.
And I don't know what that, that
feels to me like more of a
problem because once you're a
world tour team, like once
you're a world tour team, that's
kind of it's a business.
It's up to you how you how you
run that, how successful you
are.
If you've got riders who are
trying to make up and actually
get into a good development
squad, maybe get into in our
national team to show what they
could do there are the money can
make much more of a difference
there than it did 20 years ago.
20 years ago, the fastest 17
year old bike rider in the
country, whoever won the the
junior national 10 was probably
the fastest junior time Travis
in the country.
If it was very tight, maybe, but
even then they aired an average
kind of luck.
So it didn't feel quite the
same.
Now you might have someone who's
winning the national junior
national 10 by 2 seconds who has
done 10 hours of wind tunnel
time squeaking in in a couple of
seconds in front of someone who
hasn't done anything.
You think well, quite honestly.
And if you are looking, if
you're a team manager looking to
assign someone, you can't even
look at these two guys and go,
oh, well, you see, this guy is
riding a disc shave.
It's a great bike.
He's got like, you know, he's
got a nice pair of unmoulded
nice pair of moulded watch out
bars.
He's riding a great set up.
This guy's riding a steel bike
from 1999.
I know which one of them is
faster.
If it's, if it's, you know if.
If the difference between them
was wind tunnel testing, you
can't even see that anymore.
Yeah, that, that's a very good
point actually.
And I guess the problem is then
it may be the case that they get
selected to, you know, to make
it as a professional.
I guess the teams do look at the
Physiology, don't they?
Look at their, you know, power
numbers and, and I guess
there's.
Serious stuff.
Yeah, Yeah, it's true.
But but, but it's also
attracting attention because if
you know, nobody's looking at
the Physiology of three
different random 17 year olds
who turned up in the top ten of
a National 10 somewhere.
Because the National 10, there's
not, it's not even particularly
where people find the next big
rider.
They mean is much more road race
based and that probably is a bit
fairer.
But there still is, you know,
there still is this to me.
And to me, that kind of that
level of the sport is more of an
issue than the the elite level.
Well, this has been fascinating
and I'm sure we can continue
talking for hours.
And so I love, this is what I
love about cycling.
There's so many like little
rabbit holes where it does make
a difference.
And it's, it's sort of the
beauty, I guess, of, of cycling
in the cycling industry.
But what, what's going on with
you over the, you know, the next
12 months?
So are you.
So you're writing a a book.
You're doing still more.
Just finishing a book at the
minute.
Yeah, great.
And.
Can you say when that's coming
out or is I don't want to put
you on the spot?
It will be out next.
It'll be June 2025.
That'll be out great.
And then what about the?
Look forward to that, yeah.
The, the commentating is that
something you're that you love
doing?
It's, I actually love listening,
especially when you have
somebody who knows something
about aerodynamics and they can
sort of like chip in, especially
like doing time trials or things
like that.
Yeah, I do a bit of that.
I, I, I do sort of do tend to do
the world sort of world
Championship, European
Championship, time trials, a few
other odds and ends.
I probably don't do, I don't
think I do as much commentary as
people think.
I'll probably only maybe do 10
days a year.
I, I mean, I, I enjoy doing it.
It's, yeah, I very, very happily
do more of it.
But it's one of those things
you're always sort of struggling
to fit in.
And there are I, I tend to do
say, more time chatting and road
racing.
I'd like to do more road race
commentary, but you end up kind
of pigeonholed slightly because
that's the side of the sport you
know a lot about.
And they're always looking for
people who know about time
chatting because most, most pro
cyclists hate time training.
So the last thing on earth they
want to do is spend the day
talking about it.
Whereas I said I'll bring out
four hours to talk about time
training.
So, but hopefully, yeah, I'll be
keeping keeping that up for the
next couple of years.
Amazing, Amazing.
What?
I'll, I'll put some links for
people to look because you've
already got a couple of books
out.
They're great.
Obviously there's the second
weekly column and some of the
other things that you've done.
So I'll, I'll, I'll put some
links below so people can catch
up because there was stuff we
didn't manage to talk about that
I think people could catch up
on.
But yeah, really appreciate you
coming to chat all things Arrow
and cycling and yeah, thanks so
much.
Music.